ghost in the shell' stand alone complex
solid-state society was not a theatrical
film this is not ghost in the shell'
three as some people who aren't familiar
with stand alone complex TV show think
it is this is a continuation of that TV
show takes place after the second season
of that show and with a title that long
it's no mystery that fans have just
taken to calling this thing GI TS SSS
because that's a long ass title this is
one of the more obscure ghost in the
shell' entries because it wasn't a
theatrical movie and so a lot of people
have never seen this and you have to
have seen stand alone complex the show
to fully appreciate this movie because
as I said it is a continuation of that
show so if you've seen the first two
seasons of standalone complex which by
the way is a pretty good show then
you're going to have more appreciation
for this film than if you just went into
a blind and despite the fact that it
wasn't the at Racal I'm reviewing it
because I've reviewed every single other
ghost in the shell' movie including the
new movie that was based off of the
arize show and so without having this in
there really kind of feels like you know
I kind of feels like it's not complete
you know it's OCD and I have OCD about
completion ISM that completionists isms
I'm reviewing it so since this was not a
movie made for theaters I know going in
that the animation is not going to be on
par with those first two movies all that
being said the digital to sell animation
combined here I think is actually
handled better than innocence innocence
was like wow we can do digital stuff in
CG animation and they relied on that far
too much in innocence and it was
probably for me personally the weakest
element of that film here except for a
few sequences on a highway with cars
which really did not look good at all
when it first came out and especially
not today besides those sequences the
digital animation is actually pretty
good in this anime this film is very
much so a tribute to mamrie oh she's
first ghost in the shell' film there's
something called the puppeteer this
seems to be controlling people making
them commit suicide also there's a ton
of children that have gone missing that
seemed to be linked into some strange
thing that's involving elder care and
all this comes to a head with toga so
who's now
the leader of section 9 as he works with
Bato to try to solve these crimes and
the majors been gone from section 9 for
two years and there's even some
suspicions about her involvement with
all of these things there's a lot to
love about solid-state society and a lot
of fans really do love this movie
especially if you're a big fan of
stand-alone complex the show there's
also a lot to complain about and well
I'm not too much of a hardcore
complainer when it comes to these movies
there's some elements of this film that
really do get under my skin but we're
going to start with the positives first
there's something that's actually really
refreshing about this movie and what it
is when you watch the first two even
though they're not really linked if you
watch ghost in the shell' one and ghost
in the shell 2 and then watch
solid-state society the fact that this
film is really more so a traditional
action thriller is somewhat of a breath
of fresh air because the first two are
very sci-fi heavy this film is more like
James Cameron's aliens to Ridley Scott's
alien which was far more of a sci-fi
monster movie where aliens was more of
an action film this film has a lot of
action in it when compared to the first
two there's a lot of dialogue scenes too
and a lot of technobabble and very
exposition heavy sequences where you
have to pay attention to every word and
make sure that you are following this
plot that does get very heavy-handed but
this film is refreshingly more of just
an action film which was kind of fun to
watch because there's a lot of really
intense sequences there's a great sniper
scene there's a very white-knuckled
scene involving togusa and his daughter
inside a hospital and the entire finale
is extremely exciting and very fun and
whenever the major shows up and kicks a
lot of ass well that's always awesome to
watch also one named Yoko Kanno I've
located him
[Music]
in regards to anime she's my favorite
composer of all time and any of her
songs in this movie that involved lyrics
and singing are really gorgeous although
I do think she falls back too much on
electronica here so in this film is a
lot of suspicion about what exactly is
making people commit suicide is the
major involved in some way is it a
online hacker or is it this first off I
got the medical results back on the
sixteen kids we ran checkups on and
there were no signs that they've been
injected with micromachines I just kept
picturing the evil villain attempting to
shove tiny toy cars into children for me
this film falters in two ways the
biggest one being that it has far too
many callbacks to the original ghost in
the show in the beginning of the film
the major jumps off of a Ledge and then
uses her therm optic camouflage just
like in the first film even the final
line of this movie and if you've never
seen it no spoilers is essentially the
exact same as the final line of the
first film and even the shot is the same
and in the first film the antagonist was
known as the puppet master and in this
film it's known as the puppeteer
Japanese anime does this a lot
they don't seem to have as much of a
problem recreating various stories and
repackaging them into other movies even
stand alone complex did that by
releasing small OVA or original video
animations there were basically
summations of the first two seasons of
standalone complex and this movie kind
of feels like a mishmash of standalone
complex and the first ghost in the
shell' and well it works sometimes my
biggest issue with this movie is its
ending it doesn't seem to understand how
to end there are so many unanswered
questions which a lot of hardcore ghost
in the shell' fans have forgiven as very
smart and clever and sometimes you don't
always get all the answers and sometimes
things are just left up in the air but
to me I just see lazy screenwriting when
you write a screenplay and you have no
idea how to answer any of the
interesting questions that you've
brought up throughout your film and it
just sort of ends like we'll never know
well that's just lazy screenwriting and
trust me I've seen this movie multiple
times and I've watched featurettes and
anything that I can really get my hands
on from the creator's talking about what
their vision was for this movie and I've
listened to tons of fan theories but in
the end there are a lot of unanswered
questions in this film that leave you
hanging and not in a very good way but
in the end I really appreciate the
animation here a lot of really fun
action sequences
I like seeing togusa take the lead it
was a different turn for his character
and that was a lot of fun and I loved
the interplay between Bato and the major
because there's definitely something
going on there under the surface but
they're both sort of so self-righteous
that they can't admit it most of yoko
kanno score is beautiful and really fun
to listen to and overall if you're a
ghost in the shell' fan you can watch
this movie especially if you appreciate
the stand alone complex show but in the
end this isn't good enough to become
remarkable or a classic it's really just
a nice companion piece with standalone
complex
I'm going to give this film a B - guys
thank you so much as always for watching
my ghost in the shell' series the new
ghost in the shell' film comes out very
soon let's hope it's good if you miss my
other videos on the first two films I'm
going to have links for those in a
second here you guys are the best thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
you